byrd will spend six to 20 years in
prison as part of a plea deal this judge
could have given her two years but it
was clear he was fed up with her antics
i'm here
to apologize to the family
facing years in prison marsha byrd
apologizes for her actions but
ultimately judge eric johnson says he
didn't believe her act my mom was just
three blocks from her home that day that
day in december 2019 a camera caught
bird on tropical parkway near torrey
pines driving this suv under the
influence speeding and passing cars she
then crashed into 53 year old gilmore
rodriguez-walters
a single mother of three and a
grandmother my daughter
who shares the same birthday as her
grandmother
still cries for her grandma
rodriguez-walter's family and the judge
accusing byrd of using every trick to
extend her freedom we've seen her
dressed
a bright red suit hair and makeup done
walked into the courtroom
sat on the bench and applied bandages to
herself inside of the courtroom in an
effort to gain sympathy as the i-team
first reported in march shortly after
the crash byrd violated her conditions
of release with alcohol detected in her
system bird's attorney arguing at the
time she was battling breast cancer and
that alcohol may have been from her hair
products prosecutors arguing for a judge
to increase her bail warning she was a
flight risk earlier this year byrd
failed to show up in court a warrant
issued for her arrest
in court tuesday judge johnson didn't
buy bird's final pleas i don't believe
you really have any real arm horse in
this instance we're here today because
ultimately you had nowhere left to hide
byrd then again speaking out of turn
i have remorse she said their bird was
on house arrest up until sentencing
today she said she had skipped court
earlier this year because her nurse had
written down the wrong court date i'm
david charns live local now